what's your favorite like different
occasions what's your favorite drink
what's your favorite way of drinking
it's it's I've got it varies so what are
the different contexts here it's like
one on one
-on-one like you sit down with I don't
know Rogan invites you like it's a
Godfather to sit down and finally have a
talk about something it's going to be
whiskey
it's gonna be like a nice whiskey neat
no I like it on the rocks and I like
lots of rocks it won't be something
expensive because Rogan is not he's not
a fancy boy you know like he's a real
regular he's a really regular dude
he's gotten less regular the more
millions of dollars he has I think
there's parts of him where you're like
yeah like where you're like oh wow we
can do this yeah
um but he's a right he'd be like Jack on
the rocks or like Buffalo Trace or one
of the maybe a little whiskeys buying
Rogen B uh whiskey rocks
and then like that's a good one I
haven't hung out with Joe by ourselves I
take that back I was with him the other
night but like I would be cool my times
with Joe's are are always on podcasts
yeah and his I missed the times where it
was we just have you and him at the
store late night yeah I I'm okay with
podcasts okay I used to think this is
like uh performative or something like
this but it's not really no that's just
the chance to really sit down I enjoy it
because of the people I could never sit
down with ah like David Cross I would
never sit down with David Cross because
we don't run in the same circles and but
it's nice he has something to promote
and then he comes to my house and then
we can sit down for an hour and talk and
then and then or Kevin Smith like people
I would never really hang out with
Tom um
I enjoy being alone with Tom Moore off
Mike Tom Segura yeah we have a lot of
history there's a lot of things secrets
we know about each other and there's a
lot of Secrets going on in each other's
lives that I would never share on
podcasts that I that I can talk to him
about and I really appreciate his and I
know this isn't on brand of us beating
each other up but like I really
appreciate this insight as a as a dad
and as a dude and as a son
but but he makes me giggle harder than
anyone so doing a podcast is fun so
there's something on a podcast that's
performative for you with him and then
there's a party me and him because we're
trying to make each other laugh but I'll
tell you if we're going back to drinks
I'll tell you
like a great a great afternoon drink
there's a comparty spritz it's my one of
my favorite drinks I don't even know
what that is oh the party Spritz Campari
is an interesting alcohol
because I think it's a bitter uh or it's
a liqueur and it's got a weird rooty
earthy taste it's red so it looks like
Kool-Aid that's why I got into it I
thought camparion ice would be oh so
nice there's an old commercial but man
it's [__] like sucking the green
Giant's dick it is earthy what's earthy
it's like it tastes like Roots it's oh
nice it's not it's not it's there's a
bitterness and like a it's just not
great
and then someone introduced me to a
Negroni which is Campari and gin and a
little soda water and then the Campari
Spritz compari Spritz is Campari
Prosecco and soda water in like a wine
glass and it is
so enjoyable it's got so many different
profiles to it where you get the
bitterness but the sweetness of the
Prosecco and then it flattens it out
with the soda water and it looks like
Kool-Aid so I love it that's one of my
favorite drinks to share in what context
oh uh you're in Italy
and you've been walking around Venice
and everyone went their own ways and the
whole family comes back together and you
meet at a statue and and your wife's
sweating and she's uncomfortable and
your daughters are 16 and 18 and they're
like are what are we gonna what are we
doing with the rest of the day and you
go hey guys it's Europe does anyone want
to come party Spritz and everyone goes I
don't know what that is and you go
[__] party spreads now it's minor in
alcohol so it's not going to light them
up but it gives them a little bit of a
buzz where they're like Dad These are
nice Island didn't drink her so I drank
hers I Georgia had hers Leanne had hers
and we ordered another round I ordered
an and they're
[__] refreshing and the buzz is
perfect it's not too much because it's
just a little bit of champagne and some
kambari if the buzz is perfect and then
a couple of them and then they kind of
disappear and then you're just walking
around again that's a great [__]
drink you ever drink alone
[Laughter]
so there's a two kinds of a loan one is
alone like at a bar oh wait there's
other people but they're strangers right
they're kind of like out there
keep going yeah don't walk me through
all the alarms and then I'll tell you
the rest there's all kinds of there's a
alone on a train we're transporting
stuff
and then there's just the lone in a in
an empty home or a hotel room hotel and
it's Sunday night Sunday night and
you're packing your bag and you got a
flight at six a.m yeah but Roadhouse is
on and you're like [__] so you go down
to the front desk and go is the bar
still open and they go yeah can I order
something to take to my room sure how
about six Heinekens six Heinekens yeah
my wife wanted one too she's not up
there you murdered her and you just say
to yourself I'm just getting six so that
if I have four I just know I have two
extra ones and then you go through six
and you're like oh man I'm not done yet
dude I've drank in every alone scenario
you can possibly think of I've drank uh
I've drank alone in a helicopter with a
dude who didn't know I was drinking uh
he was I was like kind of drinking here
and he's like absolutely not and then I
poured it into a flask and opened it and
drank it and he's like dude we're in a
[__] helicopter you don't think I
spelled that the best alone drinking you
can ever do in my opinion now we're
getting the Weeds on it is alone behind
someone's back
what do you mean like when they don't
know you're drinking but you're drinking
hmm like uh
like Christmas shopping ah
and your wife says all right let's all
split up and you go cool and it's like
it's like 11 o'clock on a Sunday and
they just opened that bar by the
elevator in the Beverly Center and you
just sneak over and you go hey man
can I get a double Jack on the raw socks
for us and like sure and you just have
it you just go let's just and then
you're off and then you're like yeah
yeah and then you just little sneak one
sneak it and sneak it and then buzzed
and nobody knows and then your wife's
like wait have you been drinking like
yeah I'm drinking by myself in a [__]
mall yeah on Christmas how sad do you
think I am and then you go yeah I am uh
what about mood do you ever drink in a
dark place so I broke I I had a chick
break up or a chick cheat on me
uh when I was when I came back from
Russia and she's slept with my best
friend
and I didn't know how to deal with the
emotions I had and my buddy Mike Osborne
said I can tell you this if you drink
they go away and I went okay
and that was the first and kind of last
time I ever did that
because I did it I've done it I've done
it a couple times but it I try to avoid
I try to avoid if there's emotion going
to alcohol like meaning not when it's
anxiety but like depression yeah I kind
of sit in the depression because or
anxiety I lean towards alcohol like
anxiety like about flying or or
or just like getting worked up on over
something
but with depression I try to avoid
alcohol and just sit in it
um because I I because I've gone there
before but anxiety is up I land I land
all the time but depression heartbreak
all that you just sit in the feeling
yeah heartbreak's a weird one for me so
like the last time I got my heart broken
it Leanne dumped me
um we were dating for like four months
and she broke up with me and my instinct
was to have a drink my friends went to
this uh this uh middle eastern
restaurant and I told him what was going
on in my buddy of course like let's get
a cocktail and I was like I don't want
one I gotta figure this out because I
want this chick and if I start drinking
I'll be like ah [__] it
so I gotta figure it out like I wonder
I'm gonna find out my dad dies one day
or my mom but my dad will be the ruffle
my mom will be equally as rough my dad
and I were really close
and I wonder if I thought about this a
lot if I'll have a drink
dealing with that
like I think about that a lot I keep
saying everything I get with my dad is
extra my dad my dad had a 100 blockage
in his Widowmaker twice and both times
they saved his life and they got a stint
I think 12 or 13 years ago and then he
just got a stint this last year
but that's why everything I get to do I
feel like is extra and so you know he
was just at the premiere of my movie and
he got to see that and he had a very
emotional response and I got I got that
from him and I was like that that's a
little icing on the cake I did you know
the arena in Tampa was the first time he
ever saw me do stand up that was like a
little extra so all these things I'm
getting with them are all extra so I
have you know at least 74 so
yeah that'll be a tough one well at the
premiere here's what proud yeah he came
out he was sobbing crying and he goes
I've underestimated you your whole life
and I was like what music and he just
and he was shaking yeah he goes I just
underestimated you I didn't know I
didn't know I didn't know you were this
I didn't do whatever it was really hard
to understand him to be honest with you
I don't know totally what he said he
might just not like the movie
I I think you uh were hearing what you
wanted to hear uh would you learn about
life from your father
uh it's not gonna make sense I want to
feel like sometimes I'm like a
professional [__] wrestler because
all I care about is you come and see me
do stand up so whatever I got to do to
get you there but
the number one thing my one takeaway
from that man's humility and
I applied I've applied it in different
ways throughout my career
on my 26th birthday he gave me a really
uh aggressive speech
he
I was hungover and I just thought he was
going to say happy birthday so I picked
up the phone
and I was like Hey and he was like you
are a tremendous piece of [__]
and he broke me off you have no humility
you have no this you'll never succeed in
anything you you're you're lying to
yourself you're lying to everyone around
you you're not doing what you're going
after your dream I broke you I failed
you as a father this and that I was like
I thought you're gonna wish me happy
birthday
and so
in that speech he told me if I wanted
something I had to go at it and I had to
go after it as as hard as I could
and I had to do whatever it could I
could do to achieve that in this case it
was working offering to do anything at
the comedy club to get on stage
he told me I told him that's not how it
works and he said no that's how it works
for some poor kid from Harlem
because that kid needs it he goes you've
grown up with privilege your whole life
you don't need it you think you're gonna
be fine
and so I went and I ended up getting a
job at the door but I
it was it was it was it's humbling it's
really like uh it's it makes me feel it
made me feel uncomfortable
and so that humility
uh is the first time I really understood
humility and I've applied that in many
respects in like in like getting to be a
paid regular at The Comedy Store that
happened late in life for me and which I
think most people would give up and be
like ah [__] that I'm already a touring
comic I'm on TV I don't need that but
it's something I wanted and I knew I
wanted so I I just humbly went after it
and then I think I I still apply it when
it comes to
selling tickets or or selling a project
to the fans
or even doing podcasts I try to be as
honest as I can about whatever I'm going
through or whatever I'm dealing with but
when it comes to like selling things I
don't I don't have a problem
trying to make fun of myself or or
get in front of people so that they know
that that I have a show because the
thing I'm good at though the one thing I
know I'm good at stand up
and and I I say that humbly but like I
want them to come there so like I've
heard people make fun of me like before
they're like yeah I'm not some I'm not
some clown in a speedo who's one is
gonna I'm a real comic and I go okay but
I'm I wanna I want them that my shows
and you can be that guy and I'll be this
guy yeah the clown the speedo yeah it's
like what are you gonna do
funny people make fun of me for taking
my shirt off like I guess behind my back
no one ever does it to me like no one
would ever
Comics aren't Comics aren't Comics
aren't that manly
yeah yeah but I always go like I always
go like who what do you care what am I
what do you care